it is in children that the covid virus
has got a grip most of the daily cases
are in the young so half term could help
slow transmission and give extra time
for more children to get protected by
the vaccine our school's had a lot of
cases recently and i just feel it's
going to be safer for me to have it
they're not protected at the moment and
it's just running right through the
schools at the moment and it's affecting
their education this is three years my
daughter's been affected by this now
i think it's the right thing to do for
her but also for the society trying to
get back to close back to normality
again more than 86 percent of the
population over the age of 12 has now
had at least one dose but while
antibodies from the vaccine and natural
infection rise in the young protection
is waning in the elderly and as more
people abandon masks and social mixing
increases the virus is finding more
opportunities to exploit holes in that
wall of immunity
but the balance between immunity and
behavior is uncertain and it's making
hard to predict the future course of the
pandemic the university of warwick has
created scenarios for what might happen
to the key metric of hospital admissions
with three different assumptions on how
quickly immunity wanes if the vaccine
holds up we follow the line at the
bottom with a gentle decline in
seriously ill patients if there's a more
rapid loss of immunity we follow the top
line and get a peak in admissions the
difference between the two could be more
than 1200 extra patients a day going
into hospital
factor in behavior changes and
predicting the future gets even more
uncertain this is what happens with a
rapid return to pre-pandemic behavior by
december without potential surge in
emissions soon after but the slower the
return to normal behavior the lower and
later any peak in serious infections
this is the modeling for a return to
normal behavior by february those extra
two months reduce the admission rate
even for the worst case assumption on
immunity by 500 people a day a big
difference for the nhs
add in uncertainties over the booster
rollout vaccine uptake in children the
seasonal effect on the virus and no
scientists can predict the future with
any certainty we have these big changes
in immunity in different age groups
driven by different processes whether
it's waning immunity in the old or a
huge epidemic going on in the young
and so all of those things are playing
out partly cancelling each other out and
you see you just look at the aggregate
number of cases and you get whatever it
is but the big big changes and so it's
very hard
to be precise about what might happen
going into the future the government
continues to resist pressure to bring in
plan b with masks and working from home
backing up vaccinations there are signs
in the daily data that the rising cases
may be slowing but it's far too soon to
say the surge is over
thomas more sky news